beautiful code ship it looks great  but it will never work on the client  ship it this is probably someone else  will test it anyway other claptrap over  there it's already a meeting invite  awesome  me these are where all of the  productivity happens Hyperion only makes  first-person echo Sims  it's our niche just out of one 10 second  delay back because everything  Hyperion only makes first-person echo  Sims  it's our niche seriously people Rev is  not a changeless description ballad I'm  just decided that's a feature mark ol is  red I love making spreadsheets be cool  be cool do this already  best particle effect needs to be like  claptrap over there I'm blocked by the  other claptrap over there  more like meme lands to more like  Maitland's the pre mean coal mine water  means more like me me me me me me me me  I'm blocked by the other claptrap over  there be cool be cool  best particle effect needs to be like  red not big like red